okay so here's the first method now by
the way I'm gonna give you two okay use
whichever you like but you have to know
both okay
I know people don't like that especially
because they're like I hate grabbing
everyone hates prepping for some reason
but you gotta know both because number
one
sometimes one method is vastly faster
than the other okay so you're just
hurting yourself or you only know one
and number two even if you know one the
other one whichever one you used will
provide you with a really helpful sort
of check to know have I got it right or
not
okay so here's the first one use the
graphic now we've just said the lockers
I'm interested in is the midpoint of the
clock
so it's gotta be inside the parabola
okay which means that from here to here
these these we've crossed out ones that
can't be part of the lockers okay there
must be a restriction there okay so how
would you suggest I find out what these
two points are just solve simultaneously
because we know this equation it's x
squared equals 4y we know that equation
let's solve it okay so I would say and
by the way I would include this in your
answer okay especially with the top of
this please avoid just having you know
in your head Euler I've got to solve
simultaneously so you write down some
equations okay but if you haven't
explained why number one you're gonna
shoot yourself up number two the marker
is gonna have no idea if you really
understand what you're doing or not so I
would say to find the points of
intersection
so again I'm using the graph okay I'll
show you method to in a second to find
points of intersection I'm gonna solve
simultaneously so I've got two wire plus
four equals 4y just looks like it'll be
nice and easy 4 equals 2y y equals 2
okay
usually though it's restrictions on
their domain not restrictions on the
range okay even though in this case both
would work so to get from here to my
x-values I would say therefore x squared
equals 8 yep so x equals plus or minus 2
root 2 that makes sense and that sort of
looks like I mean it's not a beautiful
graph but that looks like it makes sense
okay now these are the points of
intersection so what does that tell me
about the restrictions how do I use this
to express my restriction good this is
the this is the negative 1 right so I
want to be on the left here and this is
the positive one it's going to be to the
right of that okay so you would say
therefore the restriction is less than
the negative 1 inclusive or greater than
the positive one if you want to be super
fancy you can use absolute value
notation you can say the absolute value
of X is greater than 2 - okay I've been
pretty fine so the actual locus that I'm
interested in is this equation with this
restriction and that's my answer pushed
on okay yeah that wasn't too hard yeah
hmm
I'm gonna say no I'm gonna say no the
reason why is because no more on the
topic is like the the sub point is
called position of them do me okay
number two because what you are looking
at is if you do it as um in terms of
range you're thinking of it as a
relation not a function because one x
value one y value goes to two x values
so it can be confusing right so I would
do the extra work and get to the eight
oh yeah it's when P and Q coincide so
their difference on x NV yeah exactly
right because then the chord would be
tangent to the parabola at that point so
that that chord would just be the x axis
so it doesn't pass through - - good okay
is that Alright okay now I'm gonna leave
that there that's the number one yeah
you mean which way do I go yeah okay so
that's we're using the graph right
you've got to use a video tuition you've
got to really think this through so
you've got to look at the graph and
you've got to say I want the parts of
this graph that are inside the parabola
right so I'm illuminating the part
between these two I want the parts on
the outsides right so that's why I said
to the left of the negative 1 and to the
right of the positive 1 so there's no
that's right now I'll give you a quick
question for those of you haven't lost
the question so I think that means you
understand here I said the locus has to
be inside the parabola can you tell me a
situation where the locus would have to
be the reverse where we have to be
outside thank you thank you so often was
doing that we propose you're gonna have
a tangent over here tangent over there
right so you can see the locus of that
point of intersection wherever it goes
must be outside right so you can't just
blindly picked off by be inside or might
be outside you think think about what
the locus has to do okay think about
where it can go where it's restricted